onet à monsieur lionel tardy monsieur le
premier ministre en plein week-end de la
toussaint vous avez fait passer en douce
un décret autorisant la création d'un
gigantesque fichier des titres
électroniques sécurisées le fichier tess
mes chers collègues il faut prendre la
mesure de la taille de ce fichier
il réunira les données personnelles
relatives à 60 millions de personnes
soit la quasi totalité de la population
française ils seront notamment contenu
notre état civil mais aussi notre taille
notre adresse
la filiation nos parents ou encore
l'image numérisée de notre visage
le but annoncé de ce fichier commun aux
cartes nationales d'identité aux
passeports et de simplifier les
démarches et de lutter contre
l'usurpation de l'identité
nous souscrivons à ses finalités en 2012
notre majorité avait il est vrai fait
une proposition similaire mais sous
forme de proposition de loi
elle avait été censurée par le conseil
constitutionnel et avait subi une forte
opposition de la gauche et en
particulier de monsieur urvoas devenu
depuis ministre de la justice
ce qui pose sérieusement question
aujourd'hui c'est la méthode employée
un tel fichier par son ampleur ne
devrait pas pouvoir et créer sans qu'il
y ait un grand débat public
il est anormal que le parlement n'ait
pas été saisi de ce sujet compte tenu de
son caractère exceptionnel
comme l'a souligné la cnil ce simple
décret pourrait être modifié au gré des
majorités gouvernementales
il n'est donc pas exclu que ce fichier
puisque il existera soit détournée à des
fins bien plus inquiétant pour nos
libertés publiques
surtout je doute que toutes les
garanties en termes de sécurité soient
réunies
le risque de piratage de détournement et
d'accès inappropriés à ce fichier ne
pourra jamais être écartée vous votre
volonté de créer une gigantesque base de
données centralisée présente de sérieux
risques au regard de la protection des
droits et libertés des citoyens
il est très étonnant de voir ce qu'il a
dénoncé jusqu alors mettre en place en
catimini une telle mesure
pourquoi avoir pris ce décret sans aucun
débat au parlement sans véritables
études d'impact
êtes vous conscient monsieur le premier
ministre les risques qui pèsent sur les
données de 60 millions de français à la
faveur de la fête d'halloween le
gouvernement dans le sien bernard
cazenave ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur le député halloween inspiration
pour tout votre question parce que et ya
un décalage total entre la réalité du
contenu de ce fichier est ce que vous en
dites donc je voudrais simplement vous
donner quelques informations pour que
vous puissiez partir d'ici sans avoir la
frayeur que donne la citrouille au
moment d'halloween le premier point sur
lequel je voudrais insister c'est que le
fichier que vous aviez proposé a été
censurée par le conseil constitutionnel
et que le fichier que nous avons mis en
place par décret ne correspond à aucune
des finalités n'y a aucune des règles de
consultation du président fichiers de
quoi s'agit-il
il s'agit d'intégrer des données
relatives à un fichier obsolescent qui
existe déjà le fmg permettant
l'instruction des demandes de cartes
nationales d'identité affiché beaucoup
plus fiable car récent comportant les
données notamment biométrique relatives
au passeport biométrique et en 2009
cette injection permet deux choses
d'abord donné une base informatique
solide aux cartes d'identité dont je le
redis la précédente mlg était obsolète
et poser les problèmes de maintenance et
de permettre une instruction harmonisées
entre ces deux titres d'identité et de
voyage que sont les passeports et les
cartes nationales d'identité nous ne
revenons pas à la carte d'identité
électronique que vous aviez proposé ne
mettront aucune puce dans la ceni et il
n'y aura pas d'utilisation biométrique
nous ne créons pas afficher identique à
celui censuré en 2012 et par ailleurs
contrairement à ce que vous indiquez ce
fichier a été validé par le conseil
d'état est totalement vide validé par la
cnil qui a indiqué je cite qu'ils
étaient déterminés explicite est
légitime
je pense que sur la base de ces
informations vous devriez pouvoir
quitter la séance totalement rassurés si
ce n'est absolument converti la parole
alternative